one of the best ways of gathering data
for date science projects
is through the use of apis now
api stands for application programming
interface
and it's something that allows computer
programs to talk to each other
there's a lot of them that operate
within your operating system directly
but it's also a way of accessing web
data and pulling in data live from
multiple sources
the most common api used in data science
is going to be what is called a rest api
where rest stands for representational
state transfer
and that's the software architectural
style of the world wide web
what we're going to do with rest apis is
access data on a web page via
http and the data that we get is usually
going to be in the json or javascript
object notation format
what's nice about this is that by using
this rest api
we can send data directly from that web
page into other programs for analysis
also rest apis are language agnostic
some of the most popular apis are social
apis
facebook for example has information
like that
twitter has a very common api and you
can get data from twitter
google talk is one of the most popular
foursquare and soundcloud are also very
popular social apis
you can build applications that connect
with these social networks directly
in some situations you can pull the data
in for a data science project
also very common or visual apis such as
google maps
or youtube or accuweather is very common
and so is pinterest and flickr
let me give you a brief example of a
very very simple api through r
i'm going to get some data from a
website calder gast
which is for automobile racing data and
here is what you see if you go to
ergast.com
it's not much but if you click on that
link it'll take you to the developer api
that has information about formula one
races from 1950 to 2014
all you have to do is create a url
i'm going to do a particular search for
the people who won in 1957.
this is my data in json format the
people who won each race in 1957.
now that i know what the url is i can go
to r
i'm going to use a package called
johnlight which is a way of accessing
json data from the web along with its
dependency
curl which is for urls if you don't have
those installed already
you'll want to use install packages and
i'll use require here to get john light
loaded
it loads curl by default then what i'm
going to do is i take that url from
earlier
which is right here and i use the
command from json and feed it into an
object
called f1 for formula one now
if you want to see what's in there it's
a list object
and so that means that it's really big
and just lots and lots of text
but it is structured the same way we saw
earlier
in fact i'm going to pull up the
structure here and this is a way of
indicating the nested structure
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
get a piece of that list from the
overall object
f1 and i'm going to go down a level to
mr data to another level race tables
and so on until i get to driver and i'm
going to feed that into an object called
driver
and then i'll get the column names for
that
there's seven columns i'm going to take
four of them and put them in a different
order
and then here are the first five drivers
listed in this data set
we have the first name the last name
juan fangio who won the first race from
argentina
one of the greatest drivers ever and so
what we have here is wonderful way of
accessing the structured json data from
the web and feeding it into her so we
can use it in our own analyses
in conclusion apis make structured web
data easy to get
you can get the data and put it directly
into the program you're using for
analysis
apis are one of the best tools for data
science in terms of retrieving data
that's structured and can be
incorporated into your analysis to get
the insights that you need